dominance
and submissiveness
something you've also written about
what's the role of that inside
relationships about this human dynamic
of dominance and submissiveness
um
is that a feature or a bug
so the the stable state that these
dynamical systems arrive at
uh is it good
to have an
equality within a relationship
or is it good to have differences in
relationship uh are you talking about
romantic relationships or just in human
relationships romantic probably because
unless it could be generalized to human
relationships perhaps it could be
generalized to human relationships i
wasn't thinking that but perhaps it
could be but let's start with romantic i
guess one-on-one i'm personally in favor
of uh equality uh on that dimension
within the romantic relationships and
um in the
in
i don't talk about my personal life uh
but um but i've been in relationships uh
and the best ones tend to be those where
where there's uh equality and
one person does not uh dominate the
other
um but i guess what i was the reason i
ask you is in what type of relationships
because there are some
um things like coalitions where
hierarchy is very important to the
function of the coalition
so it's like you if you're like a war
coalition or something in small group
warfare
you can't just have equality you have to
have um
leaders that are
determining the um
the battle plans so to speak
um and so if you have uh
you you're you're attacking a
neighboring group or something and
everyone gets an equal say it's not
gonna work that way and so we tend to
um appoint as leaders those who are uh
doesn't always work out well but those
who are presumably wise or good
effective leaders and they even talk
about and i'm sure you're familiar with
this and i'm not an expert on this but
you know wartime leaders versus
peacetime leaders and so again it
depends on
you know what the goal is of the group
that you are a part of
um and so and so i think there is
functionality and utility
to a lot of our evolved psychology of
status and dominance and submissiveness
so for example
and you have to look at the individual
psychology and this is actually
something i'm currently studying um
again with with patrick durkee
uh where
one advantage of these status
hierarchies is that you're not always
battling
you know so you determine um
and that's why
here's another sexually dimorphic
aspect of our psychology
formidability assessment so there's
there's evidence that males engage in
this you know can i take this guy or can
he take me like and it's like it's the
entirety of my life yes it's like a
spontaneous assessment of of
formidability
and
and it also
the that information is critical because
that means like who you should not
challenge or or who you can challenge
with impunity impunity so
um
and there's functionality to
submitting
as well you know because you you defer
to someone
so that you don't get vanquished and you
live to see another day
uh
so i think we actually have a very rich
psychology of status hierarchies and
dominance and submissiveness so
especially sort of uh
violent
conflict
yes
but back to relationships
so maybe phrased another way what is
masculinity what is femininity
is there value inside a relationship for
den for differences
you talked about meetings meeting
mating strategies with the dating stage
where you're selecting the mate but also
within
you know
mating broadly defined as the entirety
of the process
are should those differences
be magnified and celebrated
or
um
sort of suppressed
i've seen enough different relationships
work and i've seen enough relationships
implode to
say there's no there's not one size fits
all on on these things so even with
respect to masculinity and femininity
some reduce it psychologically to two
other terms which are agency and
communion so where agency is you know
are you
instrumental goal oriented um get tasks
done et cetera communion is
you know more the the love and forming
connections with other people and so
forth
um and i published a study a while back
on uh on what's where called unmitigated
agency and unmitigated communion so you
there are like good and bad aspects of
agency and communion so they can go so
there's toxic as they say masculinity
toxic femininity
you can just rephrase that saying there
could be toxic agency and toxic
communion yeah yeah and so and so some
elements of masculinity
the unmitigated masculinity is
i think terrible i was actually walking
around downtown austin earlier today
there's
this example and
this guy
was um i guess
stuck and wanted the car ahead of him to
move
and all of a sudden he screamed out of
who's gonna
move your [ __ ] car like uh and and
then
jumped out of his car and to appreciate
it
to me that's that's um
toxic masculinity if you will we don't
need that you know
yeah so in this
by the way as somebody who worked with
cars quite a long time in terms of human
interaction with semi-autonomous
vehicles it's so fascinating
how the car
and traffic
brings out like the worst
in human nature
in a sense or maybe to rephrase that
it maybe
challenges you to explore something that
uh in terms of temper in terms of anger
in terms of anxiety that you have been
bottling it up up there's something that
where the car is like a vessel for a
psychological experiment of how much
stress you can take and some people that
stress is like heating
uh it's making the water boil and it's
fascinating to see what that results in
i think if you are the kind of person
that explodes
emotionally uh in traffic that means
there's deeper issues to sort of
confront and it seems like the traffic
and the car
is a place where you
get to confront your
the shadow
call young's shadow
there's something deep within that that
we don't often fish we're alone with
ourselves and we get to see who we truly
are
yeah well we're yeah it can bring out
road rage and
also there's this um
i don't know when you're in the vehicle
there's you have this shell around you
and so there's this feeling that you are
protected from yes
so you could be yourself you can be your
true self in this moment and sometimes
that true self in this moment
is an angry screaming person which means
you have you have to introspect that
shadow shine a light